these students in hamburger learning
Russian today they're being taught to
count from 1 to 100 to help the numbers
stick in their heads their teacher says
it's important to keep repeating them
one thing they won't be repeating is an
entire grade that's because Hamburg has
stopped holding children back a year if
the grades aren't up to scratch yet for
most students that's no cause to
celebrate stink adesso it's a stupid
idea that everyone automatically
progresses it means you don't have a
goal at the end of the year and no
incentive to do well Angeles finis if
the good students understand the lessons
and work hard while the bad students
mess around the bad students disturb the
others and can't take part tiding could
do Glee adjustments it's good motivation
for most people they think okay I need
to knuckle down so I don't have to
repeat this year does he sits in labor
every year nearly two percent of school
children in Germany repeat a grade some
160,000 last year many experts oppose
the practice so more and more German
states are looking to abolish it as a
pseudo sensual and they usually repeat a
grade because of just a few subjects but
they have to do the whole year over
again oh they'll do sport in music just
because they had problems with physics
and mathematics it's better to just
focus on these instead of making them
slog through everything again that's a
bling juanita guns appellate to know I'm
ugly to neweden the educational
establishment in Germany is arguing the
pros and cons of repeating a grade
teachers at this school are firmly
against it ask Marvin d Lord to destroy
you ask the students are torn from their
social surroundings and I don't think
that's a good thing they join a
different class in a different age group
the middle school when they're young a
year can make a big difference and can
also affect how the child develops so I
think that repeating a year is
counterproductive atif does its boom
basia one we're worried that students
would not apply themselves if they
didn't have the consequence of repeating
a year then they would get a rude
awakening in the tenth grade when they
have to take their school-leaving exams
indeed I named makayla epps luciana
Shula Malmaison principal Dianna Aman
thinks that could lead to easier
school-leaving exams after all no school
wants its students to flunk their tests
in Hamburg children through the 9th
grade automatically progress older
children those still run the risk of
repeating year this is Alex's second
attempt at getting through the 10th
grade but he doesn't mind yes whoo EE
totes I'm repeating the grade and my
marks have really improved escrito he
come on I'm managing to keep up with
things and I'm making more of an effort
on fh1 zips if these younger students
start to lag behind they have to attend
extra classes to get them back up to
speed Deanna Amon says they can barely
fit them into their busy school schedule
Sheila in da children in grades seven to
ten have a lot of lessons 34 to 36 hours
at our school extra lessons mean they
have to spend additional time in class
but the pupils have to have some free
time for themselves missing arms of
light side the common
students who have to repeat a grade cost
the German taxpayer some 800 million
euros a year more children in the school
system means higher costs that's why
many states in Germany want to abolish
the practice humbugs act yeah the
authorities in Hamburg say they want to
invest money in the extra classes sure
money will have to be invested at the
start and this will benefit the students
but it's still a cost-cutting measure
avila's NT uses not Julian Bob Modell
some parents say the extra funding still
won't be enough to pay for quality extra
tuition for struggling students so by
Spivet yet stay extra lessons are being
taught by older students retired
teachers and private tutors not the
teachers who know the students
weaknesses and who could help target
specific areas does repeating a year
give underperforming students a second
chance is it as simple as rewinding and
starting over or does going back at your
waist some of the best time in a child's
life Germany might have to look to its
neighbors for the answer Europe's best
students come from Finland and it did
away with repeating a grade long ago